de forma notável a orapronobis pode
ajudar a tratar várias condições de
saúde incluindo anemia hipertensão que é
pressão alta diabetes e problemas
respiratórios essa planta faz parte das
chamadas plantas alimentícias não
convencionais da sigla punk
PC que costumam ser tratadas como se
fosse invasoras ou até pragas por essa
razão muitas vezes são descartadas de
nossa dieta mas na verdade deveriam
receber mais consideração mais atenção
devido à sua riqueza em nutrientes como
vitaminas minerais e até proteínas muita
gente divulga que a orapronobis possui
cerca de 25 a 30% de proteínas em sua
folha e cerca de 85% dessas proteínas se
encontram em uma forma facilmente
digerível em partes Isso é verdade os
aminoácidos mais abundantes nessa
plantinha Milagrosa são a lisina e o
triptofano a lisina é incrível para
fortalecer a saúde do sistema imune do
intestino da pele e de cabelos já o
triptofano é perfeito para melhorar a
qualidade do Sono pois ajuda na formação
de melatonina aquele hormônio que faz
você dormir feito anjinho à noite o
triptofano age assim e de dia vai virar
serotonina que dá aquela levantada no
astral e ajuda a combater a depressão A
or pronobis realmente tem esse
aminoácidos em maior concentração Porém
Aqui vai a revelação pelo menos os
estudos nacionais a orapronobis pode não
ser essa fonte Espetacular de proteínas
que muitos divulgam por aí entre as
vitaminas encontradas na hora pronobis
estão a vitamina A que é importante pra
saúde dos olhos a saúde ocular e para
fortalecer o sistema de defesa o sistema
imune é riquíssima em vitamina C que
ajuda na produção de colágeno e na
absorção de Ferro em vitamina K que é
essencial paraa coagulação sanguínea
também além disso a planta é uma boa
fonte de vitaminas no complexo B
incluindo a tiamina que é a B1 a
riboflavina que é B2 a niacina que é a
B3 o ácido pantotênico que é o B5 a
piridoxina que é o B6 e o ácido fólico
que é o B9 de um modo geral essas
vitaminas são muito importantes pro
metabolismo energético para a saúde do
sistema nervoso e paraa produção de
células vermelhas do sangue a presença
nessa planta de ácido fólico e do ferro
são incríveis para combater a anemia e
todos esses nutrientes são formidáveis
para as mulheres que estão grávidas ou
mesmo planejando uma gravidez porque
isso vai proteger o feto contra a má
formação O ferro é fundamental pra
produção de hemoglobina que transporta o
oxigênio para as células do corpo mas se
você está com excesso de ferro no
organismo ou mesmo Ferritina alta deve
reduzir ou evitar o consumo de ora
pronobis outro benefício dessa planta é
que ela ajuda a equilibrar os níveis de
colesterol até mesmo a gordura do fígado
pode melhorar com o consumo dessa Dádiva
da natureza em relação aos minerais a
orapronobis é uma ótima fonte cálcio
Mais até do que a couve isso é
importante paraa saúde óssea e pode
contribuir positivamente pro tratamento
de Oste porose do osso fraco Ela é Rica
em zinco fósforo manganês e magnésio
enquanto o zinco é importante pro
sistema imunológico e a cicatrização de
feridas o fósforo ajuda a manter os
ossos e dentes saudáveis já o magnésio é
necessário para inúmeros processos
metabólicos em todo o nosso corpo
inclusive para o relaxamento muscular e
controle da pressão arterial existe
outra propriedade interessante da H
pronó
conhecida pelo nome de mucilagem e que
está sendo estudada para uso na
Indústria de Alimentos mas o que
significa Então mucilagem pessoal é uma
substância encontrada em muitas outras
plantas e que é feita de uma mistura de
carboidratos solúveis em água a
mucilagem é produzida pelas células da
planta e fica armazenada dentro delas e
quando a planta é cortada ou mastigada
essa substância é liberada e forma uma
espécie de gosma viscosa e pegajosa que
tem a capacidade de absorver grandes
quantidades de água formando um gel que
pode ajudar a lubrificar o trato
gastrointestinal e assim regular a
digestão Pois é a orapronobis é cheia
dessa mucilagem e de fibras então ela dá
aquela força na digestão e melhora o
trânsito intestinal combatendo o
intestino preso e até prevenindo doenças
do intestino grosso do Colon ela ainda
pode proteger as mucosas do nosso trato
gastrointestinal contra irritações e as
temidas inflamações diminuindo assim os
sintomas de doenças como gastrite e
colite a mucilagem presente na hora
pronobis pode ajudar a controlar o
açúcar do sangue porque retarda a
absorção de carboidratos pelo trato
gastrointestinal isso pode ser muito bom
para quem tem diabetes ou mesmo
pré-diabetes ou resistên a insulina Ah e
as fibras presentes nessa planta também
dão aquela sensação de saciedade e
ajudam a controlar a fome favorecendo
assim a perda de peso ela também contém
compostos antioxidantes que ajudam a
proteger as células do corpo contra os
terríveis danos causados pelos radicais
livres os antioxidantes são substâncias
capazes de neutralizar esses radicais
livres moléculas instáveis que danifica
com nossas células e aceleram um
processo de envelhecimento combatendo
assim os radicais livres os
antioxidantes blindam nosso corpo contra
o envelhecimento precoce e ajuda a
prevenir e combater inúmeras doenças e
adivin só a orapronobis é riquíssima em
vitamina C um dos antioxidantes mais
famosos e eficazes nessa batalha épica
contra os radicais livres se deseja
aumentar a sua ingestão proteica com
essa planta a melhor opção como mostr os
estudos é consumi-la seca ou desidratada
esse processo pode ser feito facilmente
em casa utilizando para isso um forno em
Temperatura muito baixa ou mesmo expondo
as folhas ao sol para que sejam
desidratadas posteriormente basta
triturá-las em um processador Mas fique
ligado ao contrário do que muitos dizem
por aí essa planta não pode ser a única
fonte proteína da sua dieta sobre
efeitos colaterais no consumo da planta
não foram encontrados mas como ela é
rica em Oxalato se você tem tendência a
sof de peda nos rins Eu recomendo que
Evite o consumo ou ainda que consuma a
planta com moderação e na forma cozida
ou seca você é fera um grande abraço um
beijo no seu coração
comp
[Música]
Aé tambm no
can a